Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie. Marvel
just released a bunch of first looks
and scenes from Daredevil Born Again
because they've been filming
with Charlie Cox's daredevil kingpin
since a few new characters
we haven't seen before in the MCU.
Vincent D'Onofrio
even talked about Season two, confirming
that there would be a season two.
I'll explain that.
And he even talked about Spider-Man.
So I'll explain how this connects
with the plot of Spider-Man four.
I have a strong feeling that
and I've said this since I started
the Netflix show, so this is not
that.
Eventually, I'm going to kick Spider-Man.
Cannot wait to see Daredevil
and Spider-Man team up
to fight Kingpin and for Kingpin
to try and squish him some Spider-Man.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
They're going to be filming the series
all this year, all the way to December.
So we're going to get a bunch more scenes,
but more of them talking about
new characters in connecting
with the upcoming Marvel movies.
Of course,
I will do videos for everything,
and I will do videos for all the episodes
when they start releasing them.
There will be 18 episodes
total in season one,
but they are going to break the season.
I believe in a two have a little bit too,
cause if you watch anime,
they do that all the time, like season
one, Part one and season one.
Part two.
But Vincent D'Onofrio recently explained
that they are developing season two,
so there will be multiple seasons
of the show
in addition to these 18 episodes
that they're currently filming,
the new scenes that they're filming
also help set up
what's going to be happening
during the events of Spider-Man four.
So I'll explain how that all fits
together.
Probably one of the biggest new scenes
is you see Vincent D'Onofrio as kingpin
as he's going to appear during the series,
at least at the beginning of the series,
in is a scene of him
throwing a rally for his mayoral campaign,
confirming that he is going to be running
for mayor during the series.
Major kingpin like he did in the comics.
They're also in the middle
of celebrating New Year's Eve in Times
Square here for New Year's Eve 2026.
So it's 2025 December
heading into the year 2026.
We just hit winter
at the end of Spider-Man, No way home.
So this is that like right after that
and also after the events of the Hawkeye
Series, because that was set around
the same time
heading into that December holiday period.
Look, the Christmas tree was already up
in Rockefeller Center in both Spider-Man
No Way Home and the Hawkeye Series.
They're couple of Easter eggs.
You notice in the background,
like one of them
is actually dressed as Spider-Man.
So that just confirms
that the crowd knows of Spider-Man.
The whole spell
that they did in Spider-Man,
No Way Home or the two different spells
just erase the knowledge
that Peter Parker was Spider-Man.
So they know that Spider-Man exists.
They just don't know these Peter Parker.
You also see the people
celebrating New Year's
Eve, waving the banners
that say Pym Tech in Van Dyne Tech.
That's from Ant-Man, the WASP Quantumania.
So this is one of the other connections
to the Marvel movies
that are happening right now.
They explain during Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantumania that hope Van
Dyne had taken over her father's company
after Avengers Endgame
and just updated the name
and she was using
Pym particles to try and cure
a lot of the world's basic problems.
So she's using the company in Pym
particles for a lot of philanthropy.
There's a big QR code in the background.
They might wind up turning that
into free comics
that you can scan
when the episodes actually happen.
They do that in all the Marvel Disney
Plus series, like during Moonlight,
during She-Hulk, all the other ones,
even the Hawkeye Series, You scan those,
you get free comics,
and usually the comics they give away
are based on the plot
of whatever those episodes are.
I'm also assuming
because of the comic book
panel
zooming in hints in the background here
that the free comic they give away
is related to this particular comic,
and it's actually from Daredevil number
595, which is from Mayor Fisk.
Number one, the beginning of the mayor
office, Mayor Kingpin's storyline
confirming that
he is going to be doing that during this
because you see
one of the banners on the ground
that says Fisk is one of his supporters
that plans on voting for him
during the mayoral race.
In the comic book panels, you see Kingpin
wearing an outfit like we saw him wearing
during Hawkeye without the Hawaiian shirt,
like it's a similar hat.
And during it, he's thinking to himself,
the choice between good and evil rises
and falls within you, like swells rolling
in on the tide, which side do you choose?
The crest or the trough.
So it's him getting ready to address this
crowd, his supporters, the people that
he's trying to get to vote for him.
And it's meant to show you how
he thinks, why does he choose to either
do terrible things or good things?
And they make it seem like he could go
either way at any given moment, Like it's
just like swells rolling in all the time.
I could be evil. One moment
I could be good the next.
When he tries it, when he's in a normal
kind of life situation, he's such a hot
dude, you know, he's
so secretive and he's just so
he's not.
He's really socially inept. Yeah.
You know, And so it's always like
I'm like this kind of,
like, in my head, like,
I'll finish the scene as he is so bizarre.
Like, it's so weird to play him
in normal circumstances,
and because he's just not fit
for normal circumstances
in the whole idea here with Kingpin
running for mayor
is that it's meant to be part of this Dark
Reign era in Marvel
Phase five that they're heading into
after the events of Secret Invasion,
which is similar to the progression
in the comic book storylines
like you went from the Secret Invasion
of the comics into Dark Reign,
where the villains basically take over.
So it's like a rise of the villains phase
in Marvel in the way
they're playing this,
along with some of the other scenes,
like you see a bunch of kingpin flashbacks
that I'll explain to the 1970s
when he was a little bit older,
like after the events of the flashbacks
in the Netflix scenes
when he was much younger,
when you saw him kill his father
in present day, it's meant to be a dark
twist on the Iron Man, Avengers
Age of Ultron moment, where he said that
he got paranoid
after the events of the first Avengers
movie in the Qatari invasion.
In wanted to protect the Earth
by wrapping it in a suit of armor
so it was safe.
But if next time
aliens roll up to the club and they will,
they couldn't get past the bouncer.
The only people threatening
the planet would be people.
I see a suit of armor around the world.
Sounds like a cold world tie in.
The whole idea
during Avengers Age of Ultron
is they found out
that was a terrible idea.
It led to very terrible things like it
led to Ultron in After Secret Invasion.
We're getting ready for those episodes.
We're going to see the scrolls,
try to take over again.
Eventually they'll be found out,
and it sounds like
they're giving a lot of the Norman Osborn
storyline to Thunderbolt.
Ross, who's been recast, is Harrison Ford.
They're going to defeat the Skrulls
in Thunderbolt.
Ross and Val will take credit for that
in right.
That wave of popularity in the populace
to get into the White House.
It'll be a very Thanos type of moment,
like where Thanos said, Fine,
I'll do it myself,
but it'll be Thunderbolt Ross doing that,
turning the United States into something
more akin to a police state,
protecting it like,
because that's his whole thing.
He wants to protect the United States
at the expense of everyone else.
But his idea of a protected safe
United States is way more hardcore,
like a more Punisher
type of version of the United States.
The only people threatening
the planet would be people, which is also
one of the reasons why they're bringing
Punisher back during Daredevil Born Again.
Because a character like him
would be celebrated by people
like Kingpin, like, Oh yes, I want you
to do exactly what it is that you do
Protect New York City your way.
So the whole idea is
the kingpin is running for mayor
because he wants to control
New York City, control the mob.
That's why he wants to become kingpin
in the first place.
But he's doing it
because inside, like deep down,
he thinks he's trying to protect
New York City, turning it into a place
that he would want to live in
when he was a child.
Because all these kingpin flashbacks
that you see to the 1970s,
you see all these kids,
I think they're trying
to show you more context for how dangerous
New York City was in the 1970s.
Like people tell stories
about how bad things were in the seventies
in New York City.
In real life, he'll rule
New York City with an iron fist in.
The whole idea is that Daredevil is going
to try and continue being daredevil.
Like,
how do you be daredevil, be the good guy?
Because the other big thing that happens
right after this moment in the comics
is that Daredevil goes
to work for mayor Kingpin
like, how do you get rid of the dude
you hate who you know is doing evil stuff
when everybody loves him
and you're forced to work for him?
This is one of the reasons
why he was using Kate Bishop's mother's
security company to monitor everything
around New York City, like he was slowly
taking away people's personal freedoms
by monitoring everything,
using that security system.
We'll see a lot more of that vibe
during Daredevil Born Again protecting
New York City, but doing in a very dark,
kind of kingpin way.
In present day.
You see Matt Murdock, Daredevil
walking past a Baptist church,
and a lot of people think the series
takes place
or part of the series takes place
during the blip because in the background
you see on the date of the church
here it says 2020,
which would have been the blip in the MCU.
But after the fact,
a lot of people who were at the scene say
this date has just been on this church
in real life for the last couple of years.
It hasn't been updated.
It wasn't put there
for the purposes of this scene.
So the making it sound like this
scene does happen
in the present day of the MCU,
not during the blip.
And that will just be some old date or
they'll get rid of it in post-production.
There might be flashbacks to the blip,
but I'm not expecting there
to be flashbacks to the blip.
For those of you
asking about Karen Page and Foggy Nelson
coming back from the Netflix series,
I think they will come back eventually.
They're just
not in the first couple of episodes,
so they haven't been brought back yet.
The keyword is yet.
This is Charlie Cox talking about them
coming back like for Matt to
continue exploring, I think.
And what I mean by that is I think
there's a lot of fun stories to tell.
So I think this if you're a true
Daredevil fan, maybe, I don't know.
But I think that I feel like there's
probably no escaping that
there is only one.
Karen Page you know what I mean?
And that that is his
that's his his forever off to kind of one
is my instinct with him.
So he's basically saying during that
the Karen Page is Daredevil's best girl.
She will eventually probably come back
just not right away.
The actual secret invasion episodes,
like where everything
starts to set off the skrulls invade
and things go crazy.
It is deleted by like a month,
so I'm guessing
we won't get another trailer for that
until either April or early May.
I will start doing more videos
for Secret Invasion
when we do start
getting some more footage.
If you have any other questions about
what's going on in Daredevil Born Again
or the other Netflix characters,
just write them below in the comments.
My Full Mandalorian Season three Episode
five Video We'll post later this week.
After they release it, everyone click here
for my Mandalorian Season 3 episode 5
Video and everyone click here
to learn about Punisher coming back.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!